doyenne scène des scènes de du bénin non
j'aime aussi on vous propose un énorme
rôle voilà demain on vous dit on va
refaire titanic ou s'appelle titanic ta
mère est et on vous dit vous êtes sur le
bateau et on voit juste une idée où il
dessine la pareille aux normes est-ce
que je demanderai une doublure comme
avec van dormael et on vous dit on veut
c'est ça ou rien mais c'est très bien
payés c'est titanic avec le ban
leonardo dicaprio c'est james cameron
qui réalise et toi non mais non je suis
trop pudique je suis mais je me
sentirais pas sûr c'est vrai arrêtez
vous le faites ou non moi je suis pas
pudique mais en revanche j'ai pas j'ai
plus de belles fesses donc ça si le
politique passe quoi comptez-vous de
proposer nos doutes j'ai déjà joué avec
le d'hollywood mais le fait les choux
gras de cinéaste oui une petite à faut
donc puisque vous parlez de titanic mais
la scène gênantes ou lave la file à l
héroïne pose nue et capri au lapin et
c'est la première scène qu'ils ont
tourné au justement comme ils se
connaissaient pas les deux acteurs ils
ont commencé par cette première scène
comme son brise la glace dès le départ
et après le film marcherait mieux former
les jeunes ouvriers vous figurez vous
que la semaine dernière j'ai reçu une
proposition d'un film pour netflix a
alloué
c'était une fille un peu olé olé qui
devait se mettre à poil et c'était bien
précisé dans le synopsis qu'il fallait à
poil avec des scènes sexuelles il y
avait bien et kristen sexuelle donc j'ai
pas réfléchi et c'est pas du tout même
décliné de mons et pas une autre
coincé il ya 2,1 physiquement je serai
pas à l'aise a pas demandé qui était le
partenaire si si si j'ai vu qui était le
partenaire après je laisse le synopsis
au film je vais pas dévoiler ce qui s'y
passe mais ah mais non c'est pas du tout
ce que j'ai beau qu'on lui propose à ses
beaux lots jettera toile nous a jamais
rien proposé
la reposer 2 voilà d'être à poil
apprendre de passer devant mais c'est
tout si tu pouvais avoir une doublure
auxquels se serait en effet un peu
chaude j'ai lu j'ai lu ce qui s'y passe
à et c'est apparemment c'était le rôle
d'une fille qui faisait que ça ne
faisait pas que ça mais bon c'est bon
qu'on tienne cela ça va c'est quelqu'un
qui avait beaucoup de temps et vous si
rim c'est pas parce que vous avez déjà
tourné au cinéma des scènes au cinéma ou
explicite vous deviez montrer vos fesses
ans et que vous savez le faire mais une
scène d'amour vraiment dans un lit que
c'était à vous accepteriez parce que
vous êtes assez pudique quand même oui
citations les antivols correa sur
l'agout série glee assurait encore oui
pour montrer tous nos bateaux mais si on
me rentrer dedans
en tout cas il assure avec son corps
vous avez mieux que de raconter sans foi
mais je n'oublierai jamais la télé
personnel de l'hôtel à las vegas en vous
voyant de traverser tout le hall de
l'hôtel en quel sens mais isabelle c'est
une ère commence la phrase oh je sais
que j'ai raconté son poids pour que tu
raconte une scène masséna combattants du
bas voilà c'est lui qui n'a pas entendu
on roule de monde chez vous